on va se lancer sur des images d'un
sauvetage à vous allez voir très
spectaculaire qui a eu lieu au centre de
ski grauls martin à vancouver en fait au
nord de vancouver au nord de beaune
abiquo est là mais richman un enfant de
8 ans qui était suspendu une chaise de
remontée mécanique qui a retenu de peine
et de misère par un homme ça où il y
cinq adolescents ont transformé une des
clôtures de la pente en filet de
sécurité
idée géniale dans les circonstances ils
ont étendu sous l'enfant qui a plus
laissé tomber quand vous avez pu le voir
sans se blesser on le revoit ici le
centre de ski à faire des billets de
saison s'est dit fier de moi qui pompent
us en fait c'est le minimum quand même
des billets de saison assez jeune héros
pour les remercier les conséquences
auraient pu être autrement plus tragique